i'm gonna say it dude when you when you
have fresh sheets not only is that sleep
the best yeah that's
the best wank you'll have in like all
month dude in fresh sheets dude
you gotta wait you want away wait what
am i disgusting wait wait wait wait wait
i talked my time out that was
now when you put them on so fresh the
room smells nice it all feels
comfortable you're like ah
that was the biggest they had us in the
first half i've like ever had in this
podcast because i was gonna be like
yeah i know exactly what you wait what
the [ __ ] what are you what are you are
you saying you don't like that come on
guys i don't know
i don't jack off my bed well if you have
sex in it as well it's also great yeah
that's that's that's
that's you i mean you know what you said
though yeah if you would have said that
that would
be like yes i agree connor same thing
same thing
the same climax in the bed fresh sheets
all same thing dude
no like i love fresh sheets i i hate the
process of getting fresh sheets
like okay okay like putting on bed
sheets okay
you've seen my setup wow what's your
setup
okay connor has like okay you look at
connor's like gaming setup it's like
perfect
everything is like optimized and then
you see his bed
and it's like one of those like reddit
reacts to like some of the worst [ __ ]
gaming setups you've ever seen
it's it's it's like it's like a two
dollar bed set up
yeah like you just have like a [ __ ]
towel on your [ __ ]
no no so it's there's literally nothing
in my bedroom except a bed
and there's like literally nothing it's
like i don't know my [ __ ] bedroom i
just sleep in there i don't do anything
else in there
yeah your bed frame's like broken yeah
it's broken as well yeah because i
bought the cheapest one on amazon when i
moved here
right because you know moving's
expensive right yeah and it was so
expensive that i was like
a cut cost yeah i regret it because i
bought a 200
bed and that was the mattress combined
yeah and this shit's [ __ ] awful all
the springs are [ __ ] the beds are
broke
it's literally because you're talking so
much about like yeah why would you buy a
20
headset when you can just buy a hundred
dollar one you get your money here's the
thing here's the thing i i had that
philosophy
but again moving kind of like distorts
your your price range yeah because
you're spending like you know i gotta
put down like a [ __ ] 4k
deposit on this [ __ ] the flights are
this much i had to pay shipping for my
pc like i was spending a lot of money
i'm like
[ __ ] i'm kind of kind of losing a lot of
money yeah
i got to start saving costs i can't buy
a 10k bed frame right
so i bought the cheapest one on amazon
which i regretted within about two weeks
um actually no immediately when i built
it because building it was a pain the
[ __ ] ass
i could tell when i was building it i'm
like oh no this isn't even like budget
plywood this is like the
throwaway plywood that they would use
it's like the foamy plywood
i remember seeing the exact bed frame
you bought on amazon and it was like
two and a half stars and that's when i
knew that
mistakes were made yeah i just wanted
something and i wanted it now and i
regretted it so much but anyway what
happened was the most ghetto thing that
i have
is that i'm actually using a bed sheet
as like a mattress cover
wait what yeah so what happened was
right how do you stretch that [ __ ] over
it
okay actually with a lot like the
[ __ ] power of zeus i'm like
i'm like like putting this i'm like
pulling the red sea back together when
i'm putting
trying to put these bed sheets it's a
zip yeah it's all around my mattress
oh you [ __ ] sucked it around your
mattress oh you like
you have to do that every time you wash
your mattress as well sorry
watch your bed sheet i sort of washed my
bed sheet as well yeah yeah so you have
to [ __ ] strip this thing out and then
wash it
back in i feel so sorry for your
bedsheet yeah it's very stretched so
what happened okay but also i do avoid
that annoying thing this is very like
this is like the only plus in this now
i've gone to the many negatives
yeah the only plus right is that you
know that [ __ ] annoying thing when
you're sleeping in the bed sheet comes
off in the corner yeah yeah yeah you can
never get it like back on unless you
actually get off the bed yeah yeah
i [ __ ] hate that that sucks never
have that issue because the entire thing
is wrapped
up yeah it's zipped up around it no no i
i i can see like the benefits of it
because
like the the the best bed sheets are the
ones that are like
super tight they're firm yeah if i see
wrinkles on that [ __ ]
that's that's such a that's like instant
you know it's shocking too because
sometimes you'll wake up
and on your body you'll like have like
improvements oh i hate that
i'm just like yeah what the [ __ ] is that
instant soft right there
i do have a backup badge which is
actually like proper but i refuse to use
it unless i'm desperate because
i love this one and i like even putting
it back up you love [ __ ]
turning your mattress into beanbag so
here's how i ended up with a bedsheet as
my duvet and it goes all around my
mattress
i fully put it all around my mattress
and zip it up yeah yeah
so when i moved here i went to nitori
which is kind of like japanese ikea
which i think we mentioned before
i i go there right so i buy i buy the
pillows the pillow sheets you know yeah
i i buy the duvet and i go to the staff
member
and i ask him and like i'm making sure
i've got google translate man i'm like
duvet or like whatever that's [ __ ]
called blanket whatever
yeah i did not say [ __ ] like futon
i did not say futon i'm like i'm showing
him i'm like this i even showed a
picture like i want this like
this part which one is this than like
broken japanese with
google translate he's like oh no problem
fam i got you
points me to this i buy it i get home
what do you think it is it's a [ __ ]
futon and he saw me buy the futon
another futon it wasn't even in the same
section as well so that's why i was
confused yeah when i got home because
i'm like wait this is in a different
section
why do we have two different futon types
what is this so
i have two [ __ ] futon colors so i
have the bed sheet and then i have
yeah the mattress so i i got home and i
i needed to sleep so i'm like well [ __ ]
it it's going in one way or another like
it's
it's going over my bed i think god help
me the first time yeah
this is a two-two person
how the [ __ ] do you get that on yourself
yeah i i need i thought i i had you like
every time
i just assumed that you've got a duvet
now i've i've measured the technique of
doing it right
i have okay here's what i do to get it
off is easy because like it's yeah it's
like it's like
it wants to get off yeah yeah it's like
letting your pig out of clothes yeah
that [ __ ] wants to come up yeah get it
back on right okay first of all
this is the setup i flip my mattress to
the side right so it's upright yeah and
then i [ __ ] like pull over half
and i flip it upside down the other end
pull it up and then there's basically
what happens is that
it's up up to here right so this is long
horizontal
right yeah i've got to basically force
this [ __ ] together
yeah like grab it together and hold it
and it hurts my hands because it's tight
i gotta like
slowly pull a little bit by a little bit
if i let go it all goes back
so i have to keep grabbing a little bit
and zipping grabbing a little bit and
zipping
it's a pain in the [ __ ] ass and i
hate it why don't you just get a [ __ ]
it's like putting on the world's largest
car
no no no dude i mean that is the bet you
just get a proper bedroom
just get a proper [ __ ] you know what i
love the firmness of it like i love how
tight it is around just get a [ __ ]
bed sheet and just you might as well not
even have a [ __ ] bed sheet
why why not like there's a difference
between having no bed sheet
and i sweat like a [ __ ] i need a
bed sheet
right yeah so that's by [ __ ] it's
like a thousand yen i don't know i've
kind of gotten like used to it now like
i kind of like it now
he literally made a spreadsheet trying
to optimize cooking and he can't even
buy
a [ __ ] bedsheet
because then i gotta optimize that
that's another thing i want to optimize
i'm sick of it man
well too fat that that whole
optimization with the ubereats was just
a justified in myself why i can have
like pad thai three times a week right
so like like i i like i like the final
result of cooking and clean [ __ ] bed
sheets
but like like having to change your
duvet
like did you find a nice like fiddliest
[ __ ] thing ever to like take the
duvet off and like putting it back
on and having to make sure every every
corner is perfectly situated
on everything if you have a zipped up
one yeah everything will be it's not
your choice
not not the bed sheet the actual [ __ ]
blanket part oh that's easy because the
the ones in japan big brain they come
with the holes at the end
yeah you can just flip it up uh inside
out grab the thing and then yeah that's
what i always say you could do that yeah
that's what i was worried about that's
what i've done ever since you turn it
inside out
yeah i do that and then you like a
little ghost you put it over you
yeah yeah no no no no i do that grab the
ends of the futon yeah then you just
like
flip it over and then yeah shake it down
yeah and then shake it down but like for
me like
i don't know isn't that what hotels do
yeah because yeah they got a speed
running
like 100 like i don't know if my like
because i think
i have like my [ __ ] nightmare where
my
duvet is not the same size as my blanket
it's slightly bigger
so i always have like left a little bit
of fabric oh my god it triggers me so
much man
that's what i hate the ones i hate the
ones like our old uh [ __ ] duvet
well it was like the perfect size but
the problem was is that it would
the duvet inside would move around i
hate that yeah so like that so like one
end of the duvet would just have like
just [ __ ] scrunched up so that's just
trying to pull it over it's just
sheet i'm just like [ __ ] what's the
[ __ ] dude this is why i think
you are most likely to have a mental
breakdown when you're doing your bed
sheets or putting your duvet off
i don't know i i i that's that's why i
[ __ ] hate it man like
i [ __ ] hate it i don't know what it
is about putting sheets on but when it
just doesn't work you're like [ __ ] it i
just want to cry
and just be like why would it work why
would it work where's my day going bad
i i used to work in like uh hotel like
lodges
in like ski fields and stuff and i had
to do that [ __ ] every [ __ ] day
so yeah so basically like you shovel
[ __ ] out of the drains and then you
gotta go do that
yeah so i had to i i was basically that
sounds like my nightmare yeah so like
at first i [ __ ] hated it i was like
oh there's something here
yeah there's 30 rooms in this hotel that
doesn't seem too bad five rooms in
you're like [ __ ] man i want to go home
like [ __ ] like just [ __ ] around with
the dude like it's not going in
i have 25 rooms left to do this i would
actually have a mental breakdown if i
had to do like five sheets in like one
hour
i would actually be like no no i don't
think life is from yeah i'm like i'm not
getting paid enough for this
i would actually i would rock [ __ ] yeah
i'd rather shovel [ __ ] and like [ __ ]
get shouted at mcdonald's than do
five duvets in a row man so now i'm just
used to it because i've lived through
that [ __ ] vietnam war